All right.
So thanks for making some time to circle
back on this initiative.
I've had a little bit of time to review
and think about the information that was
presented and do some research and think
about how we might structure this.
In terms of, you know,
putting together a robot that makes sense.
So let me share.
All right, so and at any point,
if there's any questions or corrections
or things that need to be added,
please jump in.
You don't have to wait till the end.
But I believe this is our mission,
which is to turn Skipta as it stands
today into an integrated AI powered
optimization platform using Norstella's
proprietary RWD to deliver unmatched
engagement and drive revenue.
So two key points being there being the
RWD.
Integration, you know,
we have data that other folks don't have.
We have the engagement data from Skipta,
we have the access,
we know a lot about the physicians and
then also the opportunity to build a more
integrated platform that just creates
less steps overall and helps us capture a
bit more value.
So I think this is really the key slide
and we can spend some time here thinking
about how this might look for a build out.
There are three work streams.
The first one is is RJBD powered insights.
So that's that quick win work stream.
Where we take campaigns,
we match skip to data to RBD data,
we build those profiles for providers and
we build a a model that that is a you can
call it a look alike or a matching model
so.
You know, the key,
one of the key value props there is
you've got a campaign,
you've had engagement from this segment,
you know,
do the analysis to figure out who engaged
and who didn't,
and then find those people who engaged
who weren't necessarily part of the
campaign and add them to it.
As well as other learnings,
but I think that's a key value prop.
The second work stream is the reporting
automation.
How can we define and build standardized
metrics, processes, outputs,
documents to speed that up while
retaining the high level of quality and
oversight that we deliver?
And then the third is the integrated
platform workstream,
which I think is the biggest of the three,
which is, you know,
how do we leverage our data to really
optimize campaigns while creating a a
single place that that our clients can
come to and have access to?
You know, a fuller pipeline.
So I've broken it down into, you know,
high-level outcomes across four quarters
across each work stream, you know,
starting with the most of the effort
initially to get that quick win out the
door,
which is those RGWD powered insights.
Finding those missing people and really
understanding how campaigns are
performing and joining that data.
And while we're doing that,
we'll be doing research and evaluation
about the metrics and reporting,
building standardized metrics,
dictionaries.
Building basic, you know,
infrastructure for that as well as on the
third work stream,
doing research analysis,
probably a lot of this you already have,
but communicating it,
making it a relevant for this particular
project and then starting basic data
pipeline architecture.
So we come out of Q1 on workstream 3
having a really solid plan and then we.
Gradually shift effort away from
workstream one towards two and three
quarter two.
We build more advanced lookalike models,
add more features,
hopefully add improved metrics.
We start to automate reporting as much as
possible for standardized things or at
least get to.
You know something like a 50% state of
automation for for more coms select
things and then we start to build you
know for that third pipeline will in all
likelihood that DSP integration,
advanced targeting and kind of basic
optimization engine.
And then as we get into the second-half
of the year,
it really shifts more towards that
platform tweaks and fine tuning on the
first workstream where needed for
workstream 2,
the reporting really aiming for a high
automation rate with minimal oversight so
that we can scale without necessarily
adding time or headcount.
And having a first version of that
integrated platform and looking at
internally, making sure it works,
maybe some EA users helping us identify,
refine it. And then as we get into Q4,
it really the effort really shifts
towards to making that platform do
everything we want it to do and I and I
have some more.
Detailed slides about what I think that
looks like.
The first two are are really clear to me.
I I think I pretty understand really well
what what that looks like,
what it would mean and what kind of would
need to be built.
The third one is a little bit less clear
to me,
but I think I get the basics and I think
I just need.
We just need to share more information
and communicate more about exactly how
things are working now and how the data
are flowing in work streams.
But that's all work that can be done for
sure. And then some key assumptions.
You know,
this is a substantial body of work which
is going to involve.
Data science, but not just data science.
So we would need some data engineering
folks to help us build and maintain those
pipelines, connecting the pieces together.
We would obviously need some front end
engineers to to build the the marketing
platform.
Which we would, you know,
those 3 engineering squads would have to
coordinate very closely and then some
sort of platform UX or UI design for
really making sure it works for the
clients that are going to use it.
So I'll pause here for any thoughts,
feedbacks, questions.
Jeremy, thanks for putting this together.
I do. I do want to just just call out.
I'm just not sure if this was factored
into your your thinking here,
but we are we do have a separate work
stream going on.
A data cloud project that's going to
enable our next next best action delivery.
So we are essentially already putting the
infrastructure in place. You know,
it's not necessarily the decisioning
engine,
but the logic could potentially be be
built into that.
So you know there is there is you know
those these things would have to you know
talk to one another but there's you know
there's a you know acquiring that data
cloud piece from Salesforce and then
having that be the.
You know where we manage our our
customers and you know create the the
more you know the the setups to to
generate execution list by by channel is
at least theorized now to kind of all all
live off of of data cloud.
So I mean,
this could just be like another another
piece that that plugs into that, you know,
in in some way. Andy,
am I thinking about that the right way
from your perspective?
Yeah, I think so,
but I'm not sure where the are you
talking about for like developing like
the the lookalike model to do the next.
No, no,
more for like the next best action engine
Q3 OK.
part. I see that and say, hey,
we've already,
we're kind of building that already.
Now you know the level of we haven't
Yeah.
gotten to the point where we actually are
truly building the engine, right?
Yeah.
We're just building the automation.
To provide for like the decisioning.
So it just seems like you know the these
Yeah.
projects will have to kind of be in tune
with each other and I don't I don't want
to you know waste waste motion by by
duplicating efforts if if it's something
that we're already accounting for with
with that project.
Yeah, good point, Jake. Yeah,
that definitely side by side.
Yeah, so.
Just keep that in mind.
Like Jake said that that development will
be happening parallel I guess.
Yeah.
So I guess the question Jeremy is the so
the work stream one for Q3,
so predictive lift modeling,
so predictive lift modeling being lift.
To HC PS that we're currently not
targeting.
And then is there a predictive model for
Nest Next Nest? Geez,
easy for me to say next best action as
well or?
Yeah,
maybe they split WS1 into 1A and 1B or.
Yeah, yeah,
that's that's kind of what I was
initially thinking.
But of course it's very open to, you know,
Yeah.
doing what makes sense. I mean, you know,
why would modular modularize as much as
practical, right?
So if if we want to predict lift in terms
Right.
of engagement.
Or anything else like that should be a
standalone thing that data science builds,
which then integrates with this platform
or can be called independently,
could be integrated into Salesforce or
wherever.
Yeah, it's interesting from being able to,
you know,
predict what a next best action would be
currently. And Jake, you know,
jump in and correct me if I'm wrong,
we get told,
you know what the kind of the journey is
going to be. So what the next.
Action is going to be based on, you know,
engagement of a starting kind of tactic.
So I don't know if that would be, Jake,
something that we can.
Most of the time,
I mean it's it kind of happens in in
And.
various flavors, Jeremy and team.
So like most of the time as of now,
clients are very prescriptive with us in
terms of, you know,
here's the CP years and here's,
here's what we want them to do and here's
what we want them to do after that,
you know?
Less commonly, we have the opportunity to,
you know,
suggest what those journeys would be.
And to date, right, they're not,
they're not based on performance data.
They're based on some logic and saying,
hey, if we get someone to point A,
let's then get them to point B and.
You know,
having them see another custom message is
is better than seeing the 1st.
So there's definitely an opportunity to
leverage data to potentially, you know,
allow us to be more prescriptive and in
setting up those journeys on our own when
we have the opportunities to do so.
Jim, I would just say like I I don't,
I don't want to throw cold water on on on
these ideas because I think you know if
if this,
if this conversation's about you know how
do we get skipped it to 100 million then
obviously we've got to have some big
ideas like this and and make some
Done.
advances on what we're doing.
I will just say though that you know the
scale of what we execute and and the
types of tactics we execute aren't
necessarily conducive to performance
based optimization.
So what I mean by that is you know if I'm
delivering you know.
200 views of something in a month and the
only thing that people did with it is
view it. You know,
am I really going to be able to generate,
you know,
segments built on on performance and to
say that is like this isn't, you know,
it isn't banner media.
I mean there we do have banner media,
but and we do have some of it.
That scale when we leverage it off site,
but we don't have, you know,
tonnage of banner impressions to make
informed decisions based off things like
click rates like you really would
probably want to do to make this thing
really, really work.
So just just food for thought like it
might be.
You know, time spent with a tactic,
it just it just might have to be kind of
other things than what might be, you know,
traditionally thought about as you know,
a a signal for optimization with like
this type of an approach.
Yeah, that. I mean,
that makes perfect sense. And you know,
where we would,
where we had the opportunity to do that,
we could and where we don't, we wouldn't,
obviously. Yeah, yeah.
Yep. OK, cool.
And I would say the other I mean just
practically the the the profiling and
look alike opportunities you know may may
need to be more about and this is what
we're already doing anyway we just don't
have an an automated platform to do it.
But you know you gave us a list of.
Target list HC PS,
we're going to give you back, you know,
suggested additional HC PS based on their
patient treatment behavior,
prescribing behavior,
lab behavior or whatever else we're we're
leveraging our RWD for.
So it's it's it's more,
it's much more common for us right to
make those recommendations based on.
You know,
a matching or you know a profile built
off of the initial target list because if
we know you know who the clients are
trying to reach,
then obviously we have other ways to,
you know,
accomplish their goals and and arguably,
you know,
more comprehensive ways in terms of the
scope of our data.
And and you know a lot of times that is
you know completely disconnected from
from performance.
It's just that you know you've got this
Sure, sure.
group let us source other relevant HC PS
based on all you know what we do have at
scale which is their real world
behaviours.
So again just just food for thought in
terms of how how some of that.
So filing may have to go,
although ideally, right,
we we we could have some cases where
we're doing it based off of, you know,
performance, you know,
campaign performance versus, you know,
their behaviors in the wild, so to speak.
Right. Yeah. And we can take, you know,
assuming this, you know,
we go down this road, broadly speaking,
we can certainly do that at the start and
we can certainly then, you know,
find missed folks and and then we can
look at engagement.
And and you know just share and share you
know analysis initially to help you know
socialize that idea and build trust and
say you know things like look we you
OK.
asked for 1000, we gave you another 500,
you know these 200 engaged,
we've got 500 more that look like those
but that aren't.
Part of your campaign or something.
So I I I understand that that there's a
OK.
there's a way that this work is done.
There's a culture around how this work is
done and you know over time we can you
know try to help people as much as
possible and and find those opportunities
for optimization.
Cool. Jerry, Maggie,
it's just a practical question too.
Like how does this work in terms of the
investment and and how the dollars are
Yep.
allotted to fund a massive project like
this?
I'm gonna BLOB that over to Hassan.
So.
There's an I I S because you know we have,
we have CapEx,
right and and part of that CapEx budget
is for report automation and we've been
kind of slugging, you know,
slogging away at all the different
technical work that we need to do to get
our data in a place to provide for that
automation, but right there.
There is a limited CapEx budget.
So I just wondered like how much do we
need to think about next year's budget
and provide for something like this?
It certainly seems like this won't be
cheap. And then you know, is it, you know,
who's,
who's it ultimately on to make some of
the decisions about where that money gets
allocated across across this and and
other similar projects?
Yeah. So I was going to bring it up.
So it's good that you guys already did.
So I think we should figure out all teams
like that needs to participate here and
ensure that you know the.
Estimates from all teams are collected,
including your own team, right?
Because you will be, you know,
so if even if other teams are doing
technical work,
you'll be heavily involved in design,
validation, testing, etcetera,
and you know,
advising on data and so on and so forth.
So we put it together and maybe take it.
You know as a business case and that
business case will need to be approved
like for the initiative to launch.
So I was asked to provide overall
estimates for my entire department.
You know for 2026 I we did put some
resources there.
But that's only the data science
resources.
So I know Imran have done the same thing.
Imran, you know, attended, you know,
the New York meeting with all of us and I
think his team is will be doing
engineering work, et cetera.
But I think we need a meeting with all.
Involved team.
So let's make sure we put together all
the estimates together and then I think
one of you will need to or or or maybe we
can just have a joint meeting with Chris
Caneta and you know Diane or you know
whoever.
Is the ELT member that will need to get
need to seek approval from ELT?
That's right.
Because there there's certainly a world
where we would have to, you know,
chunk us out and prioritize it, right.
And and certainly some of these are
forward-thinking enough that there isn't
going to be an immediate, you know,
financial upside for us in business case.
It it's it's you know so I I so thank you
for answering that.
I feel like you know we will have to have
those conversations to your point and and
you know again there's there's not I
don't think there's direct commercial
opportunity in the way that that you all
are envisioning just because.
You know, our clients, you know, 9.
5 times out of 10 are like, hey,
here is my list, deliver against my list.
Do not do anything else. If you do,
you're out of compliance and you're fired.
So you know this idea that there's this
massive amount of upside by sourcing
other HC PS. Again,
I don't want to throw cold water on it.
But I do think it may be more limited
than you're envisioning now given who our
It.
buyers are and how and how we have to
execute on on their media plans.
Got it.
So actually there are two different value
propositions here, right?
Not not just one.
So and and the business value is
absolutely up to you guys, right. So,
so we can we get, we are,
we are technologists,
For sure. Yeah, no, we love it.
we get excited about you know the yeah so.
So, so the other opportunity is, you know,
making it more sticky,
making it more valuable, right.
And even so even if the HCP list doesn't
Mhm.
change, let's say, right,
there is still an opportunity to buy more.
So, so one, you know,
justify or or make a much stronger case.
You know,
by combining with RWD and producing all
kind of, you know,
um analytics to use us right instead of
someone who doesn't have RWD.
So that's one aspect, right?
Right. But Hassan,
just just the level set,
And then that can simply.
we are doing that now.
We're just not doing it in an automated
platform, but like Spiro, our team,
we're doing that every day.
Yep.
But but go ahead.
Yeah, understood. So, so,
so we automate that,
but the but the more revenue can
potentially come with building some of
these capabilities that can now go ahead
and target the same let's say SA PS,
but using not not just relying on our
third party partners.
So we can, you know, automatically.
So we discuss this idea of building,
you know,
that audience directly for a given
campaign and then going and targeting,
you know, ourselves for example, you know,
on Google and you know other.
Exchanges and that can reduce the cost
but also increase the scale, right.
So it is again the business value is
something that you guys can define right
and and and help understand how big that
opportunity would be. I do not know.
Yeah, no, that's that's helpful.
Thank you.
And we can take a slow approach as well,
right?
So let so it it's not all or nothing.
Maybe you know can provide bunch of
Yeah, no, yeah.
And I know part of this is just big ideas
options, yeah.
and how do how do we really move this
thing along and get greater integration.
Yep.
So I'm I'm spiro and I are all for it.
You know we just want to you know balance
Yeah.
it out with with the practical and the
business case but but we appreciate the
support.
And Jake,
remember we had discussed that minimum,
possibly an outfacing portal to our
customers where they could just grab our
published reports in addition to getting
them from the sales folks.
Yeah, no,
I I do think there's there's definitely a
a path of lesser resistance there that
that we could ultimately opt for,
you know and and potentially you know as
a precursor to you know a full on
Yeah.
reporting dashboard like we're thinking
in you know Q3Q4.
Cool. Jeremy, please continue.
All right. Yeah. OK.
So that's the high level. Again, you know,
the the, the point here is like you said,
Jake, throw out big ideas,
get something written down,
have it as a a starting point,
a basis for discussion.
So a lot of the rest of,
I'm going to share this deck with you.
A lot of the rest of this deck is really
sort of detailed views of what that may
look like on a quarter by quarter basis.
There's a lot of words in here.
I'm not going to read them to you,
but this is, you know,
a sketch of what that might look like in
terms of deliverables across.
Orders for each of the three work streams.
So I won't scroll through all of that.
It's there in the deck and I'll share
this with you.
But I think one thing that I do want to
go to is that second value proposition
that Hassan talked about,
which I'm calling the integrated platform
or the platform work stream.
You know,
I I tried to lay out how I thought this
would look if we if we, you know,
sort of went all in and what this looks
like and obviously this could be done at
at different levels of scale or different
components or different levels of effort
and so forth, but you know.
My ask here is kind of take a look at my
thinking here and and sort of validate it,
hear your thoughts, hear your questions.
But it seems like the real opportunity,
as Hassan mentioned to me,
if we're going to go down this path is as
much as possible cutting out some of
those middle surfaces.
To have it the integrated platform where
people can, you know,
buy space on skip to buy space through
demand side platforms all in one go,
get the reporting and analytics back in
the same place.
And then that is what allows for when
clients are ready for it,
a really high level of optimization
because all that data sits in one place
and it's really easy to do.
that kind of analytics and optimization
quickly.
So I'll pause here again for thoughts and
questions.
I mean, I I get what you're saying.
There's going to be cases where you know
that after example will work.
Most of the time it won't just because.
Clients have master service agreements
with agencies and they have to run this
media through them with their
partnerships.
So just not all of them but but most of
them.
So you know we're and and nor do we
probably want to be in the business of
undercutting our our core client which is
the agency.
But you know,
this is something we could socialize with
with other leadership team members and
get their thoughts as well. But you know,
you know the idea of, you know,
60% of our businesses is CMI if if they
were.
You know,
if they understood that we were going to
brands directly and intentionally kind of
cutting them out of this piece of
business that could potentially tank all
of Skipta. But again, in theory,
I get what you're saying here.
So, so, so actually I'm not sure if we're,
you know,
talking about cutting down the agencies,
right.
We are talking about cutting down or not
even maybe cutting them down.
So the the third party providers that we
use to run programmatic campaigns at
scale.
So we're talking about them, right.
So the so,
so essentially we did do X amount of
business with them right now which costs
us certain amount of money we can and we
were looking at something like $14.
15 dollars CPM there,
correct from what I remember.
So the average CPM S on,
let's say Google Edex,
which is the largest exchange, you know,
tend to be like 2 bucks, 3 bucks.
So there's a very substantial margin
involved there that from these third
party, you know,
partners that we are using.
So what so so so we can be but but they
are providing this very substantial value
we should acknowledge that of mapping you
know tracking down all these HCPS and and
and you know mapping their devices to
them.
So they're essentially building this
audience.
So so that part is non trivial frankly
and unless we can build.
Build a very substantial presence on a
very large number of sites with all kind
of things. We can't build that at our own.
So the idea there was that everything
that is today remains in place,
including the agency relationship,
including this third party relationship
by the way.
But then when we use things like
impression pixels.
And click pixels to essentially start
building those audiences ourselves, right,
with Google, etc.
And then we can simply sell more media so
Mhm.
we can keep the current budgets with
these third party providers constant.
But instead of growing with them,
we grow ourselves and that would cost us
substantially less.
And we can actually increase the scale
because then we can pay the exchange
directly more,
substantially more than average,
which can give us a lot more scale for
the same SEPs.
And there could be places outside of what
they're able to target these third party,
you know,
providers they're able to target right
now, maybe opportunities there.
So that was the idea.
So the business relationship remain
intact,
it's just incremental revenue
opportunately.
OK.
Hey.
Yeah, understood.
This is this is more Frank's domain,
but we'll we'll loop him into this as
well.
Cool. Yeah. And I've worked in that,
you know, world for a long time,
including my own startup.
And after that and at Amazon,
I know how sensitive agency relationships
are. So yeah,
I wouldn't want to mess with that.
Anything else here?
Sorry,
I've got a screaming child in the
Oh, no worries.
background. Please continue.
All right.
And then I've laid out just some again
preliminary thoughts about what
dependencies and risk looks like would
look like for a plan like this.
You know what we would need you know to
get have get done each quarter to kind of
go along this plan obviously subject to
adjustment,
but just saying you know if we went down
this road.
Kind of what would this look like in
terms of those things?
What would be the kind of main risks that
would come across technical business
resource domains?
And I'll I'll leave this with you for for
processing and adding and go ahead and
edit this document directly or take it
however we want to do.
And then what would success metrics and
APIs look like again for this broad,
ambitious plan where we kind of engage in
all three of these work streams and
allocate a bunch of people to it and go
forward?
Um.
So that's the presentation.
I think it's the input that I've gotten
from that we've gotten from you guys so
far is is great.
Obviously important that we're completely
on the same page about what's going to
provide the most value.
As far as next steps, you know,
if there's anything else you want to
discuss today, let's do it. Otherwise,
I would say, you know,
let's take this away.
Let's have get a little feedback from you
after you've maybe had a little time to
digest some of the details and then start
to plan that session that Hassan talked
about, which is.
You know,
what would it look like across a couple
of different teams?
What would the size be like?
What would the effort be like?
And then do and then going down the road
of building the business case?
OK, excellent. Um.
We can,
we can certainly you know aim to you know
get back to you in a week or so just in
terms of just really going through this
and and hopefully sharing it across some
more Lt.
members to and and Frank and Peter as
well in particular and then you know you
guys let us know kind of.
Next steps on you know chatting about you
know our our time investment and how that
should come together.
You know we can kind of go from there.
OK. That sounds like a good plan to me.
Awesome.
Thanks so much guys for your your time
and effort putting in this.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yes.
See.